this is absolutely tragic and dreadful
news and my thoughts are with Jo's
husband Brendan and the two children and
their wider family we've lost a great
star she was a MP great campaign EMP
with huge compassion with a big heart
and people are going to be very very sad
what has happened dreadful dreadful news
it's right that we're suspending
campaigning activity in this referendum
and everyone's thoughts will be with
Jo's family and with her constituents at
this terrible time it seemed to have
been already an outpouring of grief and
tributes to the kind of person she was
what did you know well I know she was a
very strong campaigning MP she had a
great track record of caring about
refugees and she had taken a very big
interest in how we could look after
Syrian refugees and the right thing to
do in our world she had a huge heart she
was a very compassionate campaigning MP
she was a bright star no doubt about it
a star for her constituents a star in
Parliament and a star right across the
house and we've lost a star but above
all I'm thinking of her husband Brendan
the children the family and her
constituents who will be feeling this
huge sense of loss tonight and I think
it's right we stopped the campaigning
activity we think of them and think of
what they've lost